[Music]  what seems to be the problem charlie  brown i haven't completed any of my new  year's resolutions  good grief  when our grandma didn't come for  christmas this year lucy took it pretty  hard she thought it was because of her  you are lovable and i know just how to  prove it i'm going to throw a party and  you're going to help what did i just get  myself into  should dress up  be on time  and good manners only  elegant perfection  [Music]  no one is having fun  [Music]  charlie brown how do you manage to keep  going when life gets you down  no matter how bad things may seem  i can always rely on my friends  i'm not sure if we're doing it justice i  wrote some of my own  one thing should never be  forgot lucy's party blew my mind really